Евакуація?
Так.
Помаленьку, помаленьку. Ззаду тримаю, не переживайте…
Буквально позавчора вперше в житті побачив, але закалка феєрверків трохи заспокоїла,
побачив, як з неба падає фосфор, недалеко від залізничного вокзалу.
Був вражений.
Їхати страшно, але розумієш, що треба їхати.
Треба пасажирів везти, треба військових везти. Евакуацію треба.
Усі питання під час поїздки - будь ласка, звертайтеся до мене. Мене звати Женя.
На час поїздки я ваш…
Розеток нема. Вікна не відкриваються, на час зими вікна всі закриті на зимовий період.
Це моя робота, я ж кажу - я везу людей.
У мене немає такого… Пасажир - це для мене за інструкцією, а по життю для мене це люди.
За інструкцією так, він для мене пасажир, я маю обслугувати як провідник вагона.
Але життя у мене завжди на першому місці, я до людей ставлюся як до людей.
- А гаряча вода? - Гаряча вода в нас буде після Миколаєва, хвилин за 20 після відправлення.
Зараз ми ідемо в цей проміжок, такий відрізок, що в нас малий хід, не встигає нагріватися вода.
Тому наберіться терпіння, після Миколаєва підходьте, буде все.
У вас тут все добре, все нормально? - А ви ковдри даєте? - Так. Вам холодно? - Так. - Добре, дам, звісно.
Раніше ми з пасажирами їздили, намагалися підфарбуватися.
Зараз кожну людина ось так вислухаєш, сльози оті… Самі собою.
У нас їхали чоловік і жінка, ті, що їхали за кордон.
У минулу поїздку чи позаминулу.
Вона розповідає: у них приватний будинок, каже, вийшли вони погодувати котиків-собачок.
Сусіди виїхали раніше і залишили котиків-собачок.
І вони ходили годували їх. І вони тільки вийшли, залишилася мама вдома.
Каже, мама глуха геть.
Вони пішли, а мама муку сіять хотіла, вийшла.
Повертається та бабуся назад, а двері відчинити не може.
Вона навіть не почула, як у їхній будинок прилетіло.
Будинок завалився, а вона ще двері відчиняє.
І військові перевезення теж на нас, веземо військових.
Це дуже небезпечно, особливо, коли під’їжджаєш в район бойових дій.
Там, де ми їх висаджуємо. Та і там, де садимо.
І сирени, і ракети, і прильоти.
На жаль, є загиблі і провідники, і залізничники. Дуже багато, дуже багато.
Військові перевезення - це ми веземо хлопців, яких ти бачиш, можливо, когось в останній раз.
Таке теж було, на жаль…
Вони молодці їдуть, вони їдуть на позитиві, вони молодці хлопці.
- У них такий патріотизм, що вони…
Вони тримаються, вони не тільки себе підтримують, вони і нас підтримують.
І співають їдуть, і з гармошкою їдуть, грають, співають.
Є більш скромні. Але всі такі на позитиві.
Але і ваші рідні військові? – Так, чоловік.
Наче і близько – і я в Херсоні, і він під Херсоном, а немає змоги побачитися.
- Пішов по повістці.
- А в мене син добровольцем пішов.
Я і не знала, вони рішення без мене ухвалювали.
Дитинка мала народитися, а він пішов. Народилася без нього.
Дівчата чекають тата. Одна малесенька, другій десять, чекають тата.
Дуже ждуть. Татові доці…
У школі розповідає віршик на Миколая і плаче, стоїть на лінійці і плаче.
"Я прошу у Миколая, щоб закінчилася війна і вся сім’я була разом". Стоїть і плаче.
Як у мене навесні везли евакуацію, в моєму купе в цьому тут сиділо до 15 людей.
Вісім діточок і мами отут усі сиділи, яких я не міг там розташувати, бо там отаке було.
А я, це вже була друга чи третя поїздка, у мене була можливість лягти в службовому купе на підлозі,
довелося спати з дівчиною - вона теж хотіла лягти.
Без інтиму, але так було просто.
Ми лягли поруч, лежали.
У мене був такий період - 25 діб я не виходила з потяга.
Це було в березні, березень і квітень.
12 березня я сіла і аж до квітня до п’ятого чи до якого я їздила.
Купаємося у вагоні, перемося у вагоні, усе робимо у вагоні, сушимося у вагоні. Усе в вагоні.
Кінець лютого-початок березня люди їхали і частіше казали "ми з вами обов’язково повернемося".
І я казав, що місця для вас збережу, тільки до мене.
Це як жарт. Зараз люди виїжджають з Херсона…
Щоб сказати, що вони хочуть виїжджати - я не скажу.
Це необхідність для них.
Виїжджаючи, вони залишають свою домівку, свій побут, лад, усе, що в них там нажите.
Різниця є між тим, що ми вивозили в перші місяці, і тим, що зараз вивозимо.
Кількість людей менша тут, більш організовано, волонтери організовують, вони садять, забезпечують.
Можу додати, що трохи забаганки з’явилися у людей: постіль, чай.
Тобто на мінімальні умови, які надає УЗ, для того, щоб людина евакуювалася,
люди хочуть більшого комфорту.
На жаль, це не те що неможливо - несвоєчасно, можна сказати.
Евакуація іде якихось другосортних людей.
– Ну навіщо ви так? Ви українці, ну які ви другосортні люди?
– А яке ставлення виходить?
– Тобто постіль для вас - це ставлення отаке, нема постілі - це ось таке ставлення?
У вагоні, який призначений для евакуації.
Я ж пояснюю - можете користуватися матрацами, можете користуватися, я вам дам ковдру, постілі, на жаль, нема.
Вона не передбачена для такого випадку на евакуації.
Тепле те, що… Діти, діти. Дорослі це само собою. Він розуміє цю ситуацію.
Він сідає з отакими очима, виходить із вдячними очима, тому що він доїхав.
А діти - це діти.
Він сів собі, грається, вийшов - грається. Це я маю на увазі.
І от коли воно заходить сміючись і виходить сміючись, це я вважаю тепле.
А якщо воно плакало всю дорогу, сіло плачучи і виходить плачучи, отут трошки шкребе.
- Я не уявляю, де б я могла працювати на іншій роботі.
– Ми посидимо вдома – наче втомилися, приїхали – уже треба їхати,
уже не вистачає спілкування з людьми.
Мені подобається ця робота. Вона мені до душі якось…
Я себе знайшов у цій роботі.
Ми - залізні. Мені здається, не кожна людина може таке.
Тут і психологи, і няньки, і кухарі, і кожного вислухати, і допомогти, і заспокоїти, як можеш.
Стараєшся, щоб тепленько було.
Потяги ходять майже під носом у ворога, вивозять людей.
Потяги ходять під обстрілами і підвозять військовим техніку, живу силу нашим військовим.
Це дорога життя, це шлях життя, який приведе нас до перемоги.
У даний час усі герої: волонтери, залізничники, військові - всі герої.
Тому, що ми нагнули таку країну, яку боявся весь світ.
Зараз над нею всі сміються.
Через що? Тому що наші герої всі показали, що це пшик, мильна бульбашка.
Я не герой, я роблю свою справу.
Так, як я можу, так як хочу, як відчуваю - я роблю свою справу.